I got an email from a viewer named Matt
over the weekend and he said David you
have to check out this evangelical
Christian pastor that has been out there
supporting Donald Trump who turns out to
have lied about not just one not just to
not just three but seemingly at least
four aspects of the biography that he
has on his own website I have video here
for you and this the the back story is
this is Pastor Mark burns from South
Carolina who was interviewed by CNN's
Victor Blackwell and Victor Blackwell
did nothing but ask him to confirm or
deny assertions made on the pastor's own
website we're not talking about any
really tricky questions like Katie
Couric asking Sarah Palin name anything
you read right no not of obviously that
was an incredibly difficult question
this is just confirm or deny what's on
the website turns out the guy is a
straight-up liar basically one of these
creativa Christians scammers the first
clip I'm going to play for you is that
his website claims he's a member of
Kappa Alpha Tsai which is a
traditionally black fraternity didn't
seem like it was true they interviewed
actual members of the fraternity they
all say we have no idea who on earth
this guy is here he is answering the
question himself Davis says the webpage
disappeared we'll see an end called
Kappa headquarters - they have no record
of him so when we sat down with Byrnes
we asked her about that I did without
question say that I'm I had cross and I
said I'm that cross but I started the
process of being a part of that
organization but that's the father's
that I've got is that the bio from your
website it is but it is not the it is -
by you but this is not an accurate
depiction of about you and the
informations office have been added I
mean I'm pretty I'm pretty I own up to
any mistakes that I've made like I did
with my tweet but obviously in this case
that's not so this is not from your page
no this is from my page but what I'm
saying is obviously this has been
manipulated right either or either
either hacked or added so someone took a
screenshot of your website but
manipulated the screenshot to make it
seem as though
you said something you didn't or it's
just not your page at all or the the
entire website has been hacked that
that's basically the answer this guy is
actually such a liar that I can't even
believe what I'm about to show you and
if you have children and you're trying
to teach them honesty I would advise you
to get them out of the room and this is
not for kids really here's where it
continues and it gets even worse with
Internet Archive you also claimed that
you serve six years of the Army Reserves
who is that accurate yes it is okay we
called the army and they said that you
had no active army or service sarcolemma
National Guard ok I just asked you about
Army Reserves that was my question you
and in this bio claim six years in the
Army Reserves which is it is reserves it
is the army Darmon Southglenn that's got
his reserves in a statement to CNN the
US Army says burns served in the South
Carolina National Guard from 2001 to
2005 with discharged in 2008 he has no
active army or army reserve service time
did you attend North Greenville
University I did a 10 or 15 universe'
did you graduate from North Greenville
University degree in fact the University
tells CNN he was here one semester again
the bio that's on your website claims
that you you earned a Bachelor of
Science degree did you make that claim I
asked you just a moment ago as we were
just opening up this first of all I said
we were off the record I didn't agree to
that yeah but I did I did we're still
rolling I'm still asking you questions
on the record did you make that claim
that you're graduating not fair that you
this is not fair at all this is not what
I Rico I thought we were doing a profile
and all of a sudden you're here to I'm
try to destroy I'm never I'm not come
here just for your character these are
claims that were made on your website
that was live while you were speaking at
the Republican National Convention my
question is are those claims
accurate I understand this is what media
does host and I like when he just goes
into debt slamming media right listen
you came in here with all these cameras
and you have a mic on me and
you have lights and I just had no idea
that this was on the record I told you I
wanted it off the record
well pastor were in an entire room that
is clearly a live interview setting what
on earth gave the impression that
anything of this was off the record and
and then of course he goes into
attacking media and ultimately he walks
out after talking about how unfairly
he's been treated here's the last clip
from this interview and sever hack I
don't feel comfortable at all this is
not you you also claim to this is
studying at the Anderson Theological
Seminary yes I did mm-hmm currently
working on his master of theology and
pastoral leadership according to the
church's website we called them you're
not enrolled there right but you know
how old these you're not old this is
this has been update I think there's an
updated there's an updated profile on me
that's on the website so is it old or is
it tampered these are old information
this is extremely extremely old
information seconds later this is a
thank you thank you so much I really
appreciate you coming you just take this
pastor burns walked out leaving us in
his church well done to CNN's Victor
Blackwell and have you noticed how in
the Trump world you ask basic you you
just do basic journalism and you get
attacked by Trump and his surrogates
people print what Trump says verbatim
that's a smear reporter asks a guy
whether his own claims are true after
having checked the data and at least
suspecting that it's not that's a smear
and of course they're smearing this
guy's character because they're just
asking him to confirm the claims this
this is exactly representative Jason of
what the Trump campaign is it is lies
and it is a tax on journalism for doing
basic journalism Victor Blackwell I
believe did nothing wrong do you think
he did anything wrong here no this is
just journalism at its finest asking the
hard questions supplying the facts and
then getting getting a response you
expect just to walk out on on the
reality of the situation I actually
found from supporters on the internet
saying
at least pastor burns admitted to the
lies right away he's not that bad you
know as soon as he was confronted with
basically a career his entire his entire
career was fabricated he did admit to it
right away that's a pretty damn low bar
if that's that's where we are today's
sponsor is Casper mattresses and I'm
actually now sleeping on a Casper
mattress and I love it and for a long
time I was sort of resistant to the idea
that it really matters what mattress you
have and I thought am sleeping pretty
well what difference could a different
mattress make and it actually makes a
huge difference and now I've been
completely converted into the idea that
the mattress you sleep on matters and
you can get 50 dollars towards any
mattress purchase by going to Casper
dot-com slash Pakman and using the code
Pakman PA que ma N check it out there is
a risk-free trial and return policy if
you don't like the mattress Casper will
come and pick it up at their expense no
risk to you Casper dot-com / Pakman the
code is Packman PA que ma n try it